millions of people in the South they're
waking up in the middle of a powerful
storm
Alberto's his name made landfall along
the Florida Panhandle as a subtropical
storm yesterday some areas receive more
than four inches of rain in just 24
hours
a lot of rain wind gust of around 50
miles an hour
knocked down trees and created large
waves Mississippi Alabama and Florida
all declared states of emergency the
system is moving north threatening
Alabama Tennessee Kentucky and North
Carolina with heavy rain today and well
Bojorquez is in Panama City Beach
Florida near where the storm made
landfall man well good morning good
morning from a now dry but still rather
breezy Panama City Beach where Alberto
came ashore yesterday afternoon now this
storm it has some pretty wide-ranging
impacts and that's because tropical
storm force winds extended up to 90
miles outside of Alberto's core
subtropical depression Alberto battered
parts of the south as it headed north
overnight the violent storm upended
trees and brought down power lines water
from crashing waves spilled onto roads
within hours this home was surrounded by
water showing the powerful effects of
the storms rain in such a short time
empty beaches along the Florida
Panhandle were standard throughout the
holiday weekend the dangerous surf
didn't stop a few daredevil surfers from
catching a last-minute wave until you
get out past the breakers it's like
being in a washing machine that one ride
man
you get one good ride that's worth it
but most beachgoers heeded the warnings
steering clear of the water
fearing dangerous rip currents on the
Atlantic coast the storm spawned
tornadoes went from a downpour to
justice one briefly touched down in the
town of Stewart destroying Peter Hills
trees car and power line I've been
through two hurricanes Francis and Janie
you know and it was equal to that force
as the storm moves away from the Gulf
Coast the local threat of dangerous rip
currents will remain inland flooding
will be the real concern as it heads
north and then becomes a tropical
depression and as happy as people here
are that this was not a catastrophic
event they do keep one thing in mind and
that's that the official start of
hurricane season isn't for another three
days John men while thanks